So here's a situation
You just ran out of gas your vehicles stranded on the side of a Mountain road
Who knows if we're going to get any help out here?
So it's a good idea to get a survival fire going as soon as possible and here's a cool trick
You can use to do just that using a common graphite pencil now
this trick is actually super simple to do all you need to do is first of all just wiggle the eraser off the end of
your pencil so that you've just got the wood and the graphite then all you need to do is take a sharp [object] like a
Rock or a knife and just bite off the top section of wood and
Split it down the middle so you can see the graphite exposed through the center of the pencil and [that's] pretty much all the preparation
Your pencil needs to become a makeshift firestarter
Go ahead and attach your jumper cables with the red end to the positive and the black to the negative
and watch this
Clip one of the cables onto one end of the pencil so that poking into the graphite on one end then take the other jumper
Cable and do the same thing on the other end the second it makes contact the pencil start smoking and within a few
Seconds will burst into flames
Now important thing to realize about your jumper cables
Is that only one of the teeth is electrically?
Connected so look at the wire where it runs in turn your jumper cables with the neutral side down
that's where we're going to place the wood part of our pencil and when we close the teeth the pointy part - the one with
The cable on it should be digging into the graphite like this
Now rather than burning up the entire length of your pencil at once
It makes a lot more sense to break them into one and a half to two inch pieces you end up with four to five
Different igniters by doing this you can really make one pencil go a long way the second you clip your jumper cable into place
It's going to ignite into fire
So you need to have a tinder bundle or some kind of kindling ready to go to catch that flame the instant it happens
Now the wood that you take off your pencil does not need to go to waste you can use that for
Kindling to help stoke your fire
Just chop it into small pieces pile it up in a little teepee shape and then when you get your initial flame
You'll already [have] a little more tinder. You can throw straight on the fire
Now check this out if you can stretch your jumper cables out right to your fire pit
[you] can actually get your mechanism
Set up in the fire build your tinder and your kindling over top of it
And then you can go back to your battery and connect your jumper cables to the terminals there and from a safe distance
Your fire will ignite itself how cool is that?
boom there it is
Well that is how you make a survival fire using the jumper cables from your car and a pencil?
Thanks so much for [joining] me for this experiment. I'll be looking for in the next video. Let's talk to you that
Think we just got recognized
for sure
busted